welcome to our choice today bureaucratic
despotism or the Constitution an online
town hall sponsored by hillsdale college
and its L&P Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
I'm David Bob director of the kirby
center welcome to all of you who are
participating this in this constitution
Town Hall those gathered here at the
kirby center on capitol hill and coast
to coast across this country via webcast
in the articles of association of
Hillsdale College the founders of the
college said that they were quote
grateful to god for the inestimable
blessings resulting from the prevalence
of civil and religious liberty and
intelligent piety in the land they
believed as we do today that the
diffusion of sound learning is essential
to the perpetuity of those blessings the
inestimable blessings of our American
liberty do not come automatically nor is
their perpetuity guaranteed today the
blessings of liberty made possible by
the enduring principles and structural
integrity of the American Constitution
are threatened by a bureaucracy who's
creeping despotism is all around us our
choice today it's important to note is
not one that breaks down mainly along
party lines as a former vice president
of the United States quipped a
bureaucrat is a Democrat who holds some
office that a Republican once government
at the national level has grown by leaps
and bounds as exponential increases in
deficit spending continue to fund an
ever-growing administrative state as
bloated as big government is the peril
of bureaucratic despotism is more than
just the size of the federal government
it is as importantly what scope the
federal government takes America's
founders knew that the national
government had to be strong enough to
protect the nation from foreign attack
and to ensure a republican form of
government in the states
government could not be so weak that the
god-given rights of the people were left
unprotected the federal government had
to do the things that was
constitutionally charged to do so that
the people could be free and prosper if
the federal government sought to do too
much those essential things that was
constitutionally required to do or in
danger of being left undone if you are
interested in reading the primary source
documents that define the debate that
we're going to be discussing today that
debate between the founding and the
progressive understanding of the
Constitution hillsdale college press has
just released a collection of 113
essential primary source documents it
captures that choice that is before us
today more information about the US
Constitution a reader is available
online at Hillsdale US Constitution calm
as you consider today's presentations by
hillsdale college president larry yarn
and hillsdale politics professors kevin
Porteous and rj post read oh please
submit your questions to them via email
at the email address town hall at
Hillsdale edu please include also your
name city and state our first speaker
today Senator Mike Lee has a
long-standing and strong attachment to
the principles of the American
Constitution a graduate of Brigham Young
University and also the BYU law school
mr. Lee served as a clerk for United
States Supreme Court Samuel Alito having
gone on to practice law and
distinguished private and public
capacities he saw our dearth of real
constitutional debate in his home state
of Utah and to redress this problem he
started article 1 societies across the
state gathering of citizens who were
interested in keeping government to its
constitutionally limited function in
2010 he was elected he was elected
united states senator from Utah becoming
that state's 16th senator a national
advocate for constitutionally limited
government he supports efforts to regain
fiscal responsibility individual liberty
and economic
disparity centered really is a member of
the Judiciary Committee the Foreign
Relations Committee and the Joint
Economic Committee this today he will
speak to us on the topic how the federal
bureaucracy undermines American liberty
please join me in welcoming the
Honorable Mike Lee
thank you dr. Bob and dr. Oren it's a
pleasure to be here with you today to
speak at Hillsdale College one of my
favorite institutions today I want to
speak about how the growth of the
administrative state threatens the
Liberty we enjoy under the Constitution
when the founders of our great Republic
broke away from the tyrannical rule of
Great Britain and declared independence
they wrote that governments are
instituted among men to secure our
rights and that among these rights are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness when about a decade later the
framers debated and drafted the
constitution they carefully followed
this vision of government and created a
document that secures our Liberty by
restraining government power in
discussing the ways the Constitution
limits government power we often first
think of the guarantees set forth in the
bill of rights these rights are
supremely important but at the same time
as Justice Scalia pointed out in a
recent hearing before the Senate
Judiciary Committee every banana
republic has a bill of rights what
really sets hours apart from other
constitutional Republic's is the
structure of the government that our
Constitution created after all the word
constitution itself means structure or
the physical character of a body as we
say when a person has a particular
constitutional construction essential to
the governing structure created by our
Constitution is the separation of
government powers the Constitution
separates government power in three
distinct branches article one vessel
legislative powers in a congress of the
united states which shall consist of a
senate and a House of Representatives
article two vests the executive power in
a president of the United States of
America and article three vests the
judicial power of the United States in
one supreme court and in such inferior
courts as the Congress may from time to
time ordain and establish as the Supreme
Court has recently noted and repeatedly
noted the principle of separation of
powers was not just an abstract
generalization from the framers it was
woven into the document that they
drafted in Philadelphia and the
of 1787 they considered separation of
government powers essential to the
preservation of liberty in the Supreme
Court's words it was the central
judgment of the framers that within our
political scheme the separation of
government powers into three coordinate
branches is essential to the
preservation of Liberty James Madison
set up the principle of separation of
powers that no political truth is
certainly a greater intrinsic value or a
stamped with the authority of more
enlightened patrons of Liberty the
Constitution's separation of government
powers protects our Liberty in a number
of ways by dividing government power
into three branches each of which has
its own ambition for power the
Constitution ensures that different
branches may act as checks and balances
on each other this ensures that no one
branch will be able to exercise too much
government power separation of
government powers also protects against
any one branch exercising two
fundamental powers at the same time thus
no single branch can make a law and
execute or enforce that law and no
single branch can make a law and judge
whether that law has been violated the
framers foresaw the danger of such a
fusion of powers quoting the French
political thinker montesquieu who laid
the intellectual framework for
separation of powers James Madison wrote
in Federalist 47 when the legislative
and executive powers are united in the
same person or body there can be no
Liberty because apprehensions may arise
less the same body should enact
tyrannical laws to execute them in a
tyrannical manner separation of
government powers also increases the
government's transparency and
accountability when the government acts
the public can determine which branch
has exercised its power and can hold
that branch accountable for its own
actions of course over the years there
have been many including many justices
of the US Supreme Court who have argued
that it is simply not practical to
expect the separation of government
powers to be absolute they argue that
some
overlap of legislative executive and
judicial power it's necessary for the
government to work a prominent
articulation of this argument was made
by Justice Jackson in his concurring
opinion in Youngstown Sheet in two
verses Sawyer he said that in defusing
power to secure liberty the Constitution
contemplates that that practice will
integrate the dispersed powers into a
workable government it enjoins upon the
branches separateness but
interdependence autonomy but reciprocity
it is true that the Constitution's
separation of powers does not mean that
the branches have no influence on each
other's actions otherwise the branches
could not serve as checks and balances
on each other as James Madison explained
the separation of powers doctrine does
not mean that the branches ought to have
no partial agency in or no control over
the acts of each other rather to
maintain the separation of government
powers and to accomplish the system of
checks and balances the Constitution
contemplates the branches of government
are in Madison's words connected and
blended as to give each a constitutional
control over the others the
interdependence of the different
branches of government is not however
something that the government is allowed
to make up as it goes along the
Constitution itself specifies a number
of limited exceptions to the structural
partition of power for example the
Constitution provides the president with
limited legislative rolls through his
veto and presentment powers the vice
president has a limited legislative role
in breaking the tie vote in the Senate
the Senate confirms executive and
judicial officers and ratifies treaties
and Congress may impeach and remove
judicial officers the fact that the
Constitution provides for these minor
deviations from an otherwise strict
separation only emphasizes how seriously
we have to take this structure as
Jefferson explain the principle of the
Constitution is that of a separation of
legislative executive and judiciary
functions except in cases specified if
this principle be not expressed in
direct terms it is clearly the spirit of
the Constitution and it ought to be so
commented and acted on by every friend
free government in the face of increased
pressure from politicians and judges to
blur the lines it is vital that we not
treat the Constitution as though it were
no more than a generalized prescription
that the functions of the branches
should not be commingled too much the
Constitution's more than that and as we
shall see there is much at stake when we
don't take seriously this structure to
see the dangers to our liberty posed by
our governments increasing willingness
to blur the lines of the Constitution's
separation of powers principles we need
to look no further than the current
gargantuan administrative state to
explain how the administrative state
violates the Constitution's separation
of powers and threatens our liberty we
must first take a step back as I
mentioned just a moment ago the
Constitution expressly states that all
legislative powers shall be vested in
the Congress the 17th century political
philosopher John Locke whose ideas the
framers consulted in drafting our
Constitution explained that the power of
the legislative being derived from the
people by a positive voluntary grant and
institution can be no other than what
the positive grant conveyed which being
only to make laws and not to make
legislators the legislative can have no
power to transfer their authority of
making laws and place it in other hands
in other words we the people elect
legislators to enact our nation's laws
that is a power that we give to our duly
elected legislators and a power the
Constitution does not allow them to give
to anyone else in the Supreme Court's
words that Congress cannot delegate
legislative power to the president is a
principle universally recognized as
vital to the integrity and maintenance
of the system of government
ordained by the Constitution this
constitutional principle protects our
liberty in a number of respects a few of
which I want to discuss briefly with you
right now first it limits the scope and
the volume of legislation one government
enacts laws that regulate what
individuals can and cannot do it
obviously restricts our basic Liberty
for that very reason the Constitution
created process that makes it quite
difficult to enact legislation Justice
Scalia explained that all those some see
all the disagreement and all the
argument that goes into the legislative
process and they tend to label that
dysfunctional the truth is that the
framers intentionally set up the
Constitution so that power would
contradict power and would create
legislative gridlock the framers did
this because as Alexander Hamilton noted
in Federalist number 62 the disease to
which our governments are most liable is
not a lack of legislation but rather the
excess of lawmaking the process for
enacting legislation in this country is
clearly spelled out in the constitution
article 1 section seven Clause 2 of the
Constitution provides that every bill
which shall have passed the House of
Representatives and the Senate shall
before it becomes law be presented to
the President of the United States as
the supreme court noted in I nsv chadda
the Constitution's prescription for
legislative action in article 1 sections
one and seven represents the framers
decision that the legislative power of
the federal government cannot or that it
must rather be exercised in accord with
a single finally rock and exhaustively
considered procedure but the government
does not operate according to this
single procedural the single procedure
involving bicameral passage and
presentment when it's an executive
branch an administrative agency like for
example the EPA that prom
gates law through regulation instead the
administrative agency must comply only
with certain procedures specified in a
statute known as the Administrative
Procedure Act that act specifies that an
agency must provide notice of its
intention to promulgate a law and must
allow for the public to comment on that
proposed law but the Administrative
Procedure Act imposes no real constraint
on what the agency can ultimately do in
fact a court reviewing an agency law can
strike it down only if the agency action
was arbitrary and capricious now it's
not very comforting to think that there
are tens of thousands of coercive laws
on the books that are considered valid
only because they were not so terrible
as to be judged arbitrary and capricious
and of course the result of all this is
that we have many many more national
laws on the books than the framers ever
intended us to have in some of the
Constitution's intentionally onerous
procedure for enacting legislative
legislation and it's bicameralism
principles cannot protect us from
excessive legislation if the government
simply ignores that required procedure
mandated by the Constitution another way
the Constitution's requirement that only
Congress exercise legislative power
protects our Liberty is by ensuring that
the democratic process works properly
such that the government is accountable
for the laws and an axe as Chief Justice
William Rehnquist explained by requiring
the elected legislature to make our laws
we ensure that important choices of
social policy are made by Congress the
branch of government that are that is
most responsive to the popular will the
Supreme Court echoed that sentiment in
insp chadha where it stated by providing
that no law could take effect without
the concurrence of the prescribed
majority of the members of both the
houses of Congress the framers
reemphasize their belief that
legislation should not be enacted unless
it has been carefully and fully
considered by the nation's elected
officials this is an important point if
Congress enacts a really bad law
citizens will notice and they may choose
to retire members of Congress who voted
for that
law in that respect that people can hold
their legislators accountable for the
misuse of government power and on the
other hand when executive agencies
overstep their bounds and do not simply
execute and enforce the laws but also
make laws it's not clear what citizens
can do about it the bureaucrats who make
up administrative agencies are not
elected so that people can't vote them
out of office parenthetically this same
separation of powers problem occurs when
judges go beyond their bounds and they
legislate from the bench federal judges
are not elected and thus should not be
making federal policy and law despite
these and other important considerations
behind the framers decision to vest the
legislative power in the Congress alone
when we look at all the laws and
regulations that are passed in this
country each year most of them most of
the nation's legislative powers are
exercised not by our elected legislature
the Congress but rather by
administrative agencies that are not
part that are part of the executive
branch the Federal Register which
publishes the laws and regulations
promulgated by administrative agencies
each year grew by over 80,000 pages just
this last year by contrast the US Code
which publishes laws enacted by Congress
grew by less than 3,000 pages the
majority of our country's laws are not
made by our elected legislature but
rather by unelected bureaucrats and this
is a problem perhaps some would quibble
with the definition of legislative
activity and argue that administrative
agencies are not necessarily legislating
but rather simply administering broad
congressional enactments in fact over
time and after countless attempts by
Congress to delegate much of its
legislative power to these agencies even
the Supreme Court has acquiesced to this
view and allowed broad delegations of
power to executive branch agencies as
long as Congress provides that agency
and intelligible principle to guide its
actions of course no one really disputes
that it's constitutionally proper for
administrative agencies to execute and
enforce
our country's laws indeed those agencies
may even need to make regulations
necessary to enforce the law whether
that be specifying the hours the lights
will come on in various department
buildings or the manner and procedure
for enforcing the laws unfortunately our
country's administrative agencies have
gone well beyond these limits and there
can be little dispute that much of what
they do is legislative activity when
which rightfully belongs only to the
legislative branch Congress although
there is no single definition of what
constitutes legislative activity most
would agree that to legislate is to make
generally applicable rules that have the
force of law for example in insp chaddha
the supreme court stated that a
government action was legislative
because it had the purpose and effective
altering the legal rights duties and
relations of persons outside the
legislative branch under that definition
the actions of administrative agencies
easily qualify as legislative every year
administrative agencies promulgate
hundreds if not thousands of laws that
have the effect of altering the legal
rights duties and relations of all
citizens but regardless of the precise
definition used it's plain that the bulk
of what administrative agencies do today
is legislative activity even some
liberal members of the Supreme Court
have stated that we should no longer
pretend that agencies do not legislate
and should instead simply admit that
agency rulemaking authority is
legislative power these justices
correctly noted that if the rules that
agencies so often promulgate had been
prescribed by Congress everyone would
agree that those rules would be the
product and of an exercise of
legislative power it's therefore clear
that the current administrative state
with its aggressive exercise of
legislative power violates the
Constitution's separation of powers
principle and as can be expected one
Constitution's safeguard safeguards are
ignored this practice has some dire
consequences because bureaucrats cannot
be effectively held accountable and they
seem to measure their success by the
number of new laws and regulations they
can enact businesses and citizens alike
are left swimming in a sea of seemingly
unending laws restrictions and rules
this over-regulation subsumes the free
market imposing paperwork roadblocks and
costs on businesses present preventing
the growth of our economy that it needs
to provide jobs for those seeking work
in all this very little is known or
understood about what these massive
administrative agencies are doing at any
given time and why they're doing so much
in saying this I must note that I am far
from the only person who fears the
consequences of our big bad and
unaccountable administrative state to
take but one example a highly cited
article in the Harvard Law Review from
2001 said the following bureaucracy is
the ultimate black box of government the
place where exercises of coercive power
are most unfathomable and thus most
threatening to a great extent this will
always be so the bureaucratic form and
its proportions its reach in its
distances impervious to full public
understanding much much less control
that article was written by elena kagan
now a member of the supreme court i can
think safely that Justice Kagan and I do
not agree on all political issues but
apparently we do agree on the threat
posed by the administrative state to
constrain the overwhelming appetites of
the administrative state and the threat
to Liberty it constitutes we must
enforce the Constitution separation of
government powers and insist that
Congress alone exercise the government's
proper legislative power in doing this
we cannot rely on the courts alone the
Constitution nowhere suggests that the
judiciary is the only branch charged
with faithful interpretation and
implementation of the Constitution
indeed the framers would have been
astonished at such a notion to the
contrary Thomas Jefferson wrote that the
opinion which gives to the judges their
right to decide what laws are
constitutional and what or not not only
for themselves within their own sphere
of action but for the legislature and
the executive also and their spheres
would make the judiciary a despotic
branch so far from assigning
interpretation and protection of the
Constitution to the judicial branch the
Constitution mandates that the President
and each member of Congress take an oath
to be faithful to the Constitution it's
the duty of all three branches
faithfully to interpret and implement
the Constitution's limits on power with
that in mind we as citizens must hold
Congress and the president accountable
for their treatment of the Constitution
separation of powers Congress must not
pass any more laws that broadly delegate
legislative power to unelected agencies
and to the extent possible we must hold
the president accountable for the
excessive volume of regulations
promulgated by administrative agencies
within the executive branch Congress
must also take measures to regain the
legislative powers that past congresses
have unconstitutionally delegated to
executive agencies one such measure of
which I am an original co-sponsor in the
Senate is the reins Act arraigns is
short for regulations from the executive
in need of scrutiny the Act would
mandate that any rule promulgated by an
executive agency that would have an
annual economic impact of one hundred
million dollars or more must receive a
vote by Congress if a majority of each
house of Congress does not vote in favor
of that significant regulation or the
president doesn't sign it into law it
will not go into effect the reins act
has already passed in the House of
Representatives and I'm hopeful it'll
also pass in the Senate I believe this
enactment of this legislation would be a
very important first step toward
regaining some of that Liberty we've
lost as a result of the expansion of the
administrative state it hardly seems
controversial to require the Congress
and the president to account for the
significant exercises of legislative
power represented by major
administrative actions in fact the
current situation is such that if we
were to proceed without the reins act
we'd be in bad bad shape it's absolutely
essential that we constrain this
coercive power
that the administrative state has on the
US economy so many dollars of us
industry each year have been expended
complying with this work and and we have
to rein in this work that's been
accomplished by unelected bureaucrats
who in so many cases are part of
so-called independent agencies that not
even the President of the United States
himself controls this is a dangerous
situation with so many out of work in an
economy stagnated by burdensome
regulation we have to do what we can to
reduce the size of the administrative
state stimulate our economy and regain
the Liberty that has made America the
envy of the world we have to elect
representatives who will consciously
interpret the Constitution and make sure
that we stick to the original meaning we
have to elect a president that will do
the same and who will appoint judges who
will also respect those limits we can
restore this vision above the founding
fathers to restore limited power and
safeguard the liberty of our founding
fathers that was purchased for us each
of us at so great a price but in order
to do that we have to vote we have to
speak our minds and most importantly we
have to reclaim that birthright which is
ours which is created by the
Constitution that birthright cannot take
full effect unless or until we demand
that laws are passed in the manner
prescribed by article 1 sections one and
seven of the US Constitution if we'll do
these things we will again regain our
liberty and our greatness as a nation
thank you